how's your head in your heart today
they're good they're a little confused I
mean for one thing you know we had we
did the final episode last night and we
have had a lot of things to do together
today so there's this weird feeling of
like oh no we're not really done and in
some ways you're not but so but even
without that I think it's gonna be a
long time before my head really wraps
around the fact that I'm not gonna go
back and do this that I'm not gonna
report back and for a new season and see
everybody on a regular basis and I don't
know you know it'll be it'll be a long
time before I ever if not a lifetime
until I really understand the effect
this has had on my life and it's such a
long time how about that I mean how has
your life changed before Big Bang and
now twelve years later your lifestyle
just your life is yeah
I mean there's some obvious ways in
which you know more people Know Who I am
I've I've been a working actor for 12
years straight and that's kind of insane
in this industry but then there are many
ways in which it's it's really hard for
me to know and and the funny thing is
the way in which something like this
when it goes on this long and it has
this much of an impact how it affects
the people closest to you your family
your close friends it just they all get
swept up in not in a bad way but like
there's such a part of your system and
maybe it's just a stupid little like
small version of an entourage but it's
it's it's more complex than that in some
ways and like I've noticed as we've been
wrapping this up they have feelings
about this wrapping up and I didn't mean
to be selfish but I kind of didn't think
about that my mother god bless her she
has been a puddle of tears I know this
is hard for her I'm sorry mother like 12
years was a long time
we're doing a tissue count with you and
your mama where are we
I'm I'm a five she's a 15
she's a fifty and you know she's pump
everybody dismisses Kunal Kunal come
from what's going on with Kunal no
really gonna be ridiculous but he's so
sweet
yeah I I just I don't know you you know
what it is - it's I think it is more
complicated for those closest to any
situation like this and if you're a
couple of steps back you kind of have a
freedom to be a little more like clear
about it and emotional about it or
whatever and this is a little more to be
involved you're like a lot of stuff
going on you know what I mean
[Music]
[Applause]